detect investigate protect welcome to  olaf  the european anti-fraud office  well-protected eu citizens money  it's your right it's our role  every year the eu invests over a hundred  billion euros to improve the lives of eu  citizens  and support development abroad this  money  your money is meant to make a positive  difference  yet fraudsters target these funds fraud  directly endangers your well-being and  threatens the eu environment  fraudsters operate quickly and swiftly  across borders  it's hard for member states to cope on  their own this is where  olaf the european anti-fraud office  comes in  olaf fights fraud corruption and other  illegal activities  against the eu budget  skilled olaf investigators work to  ensure criminals cannot act with  impunity  and eu funds are put to good use  olaf detect investigate  protect  you